hi guys how's it going I'm in a frenzied
what's up what's gonna work for like
frenzied but not chaotic like I'm I'm
uppity but not emotional I guess I'm
just in like a let's get sup done sort
of mode right now probably because I've
had this is number three and I told
myself that I only wanted to have two
cups of coffee a day
so sometimes we are our worst enemies
you know I'm saying anyway um so I had
an audition today which is fun always a
super fun time and then I came back from
my audition and I went to the deli to
actually get some whipped cream to put
in my coffee because I am a fancy-pants
girl and I like what claim and my coffee
and when I was there I'm wearing like a
skirt and I normally don't look like
this when I go to the deli over there
and there's a station woman behind the
counter different Asian woman from the
one that I wrote about in my blog post a
while back Oh were you following my blog
if you're not it's in the description
box below anyway I get to the deli and
I'm paying for my whipped cream and
she's looking me she goes oh yeah I'm
not gonna do an Asian accent because it
will just be offensive she said oh
you're very pretty and I said thank you
very much it's very kind of you you're
very pretty
thank you very much man well she's very
pretty and I looked over and little
giggling Manuel said yes I said thank
you she said you do TV and they said um
sort of yeah she said oh oh I could tell
you motto and I said no no um I do
comedy and she said oh that's different
and then just rang me up and I left with
my whipped cream so that was fun anyway
speaking of comedy Michelle and I have a
stage show happening this Sunday at 7
p.m. at the people's Improv Theater who
out there is in New York anyone you want
to come see a show for 5 dollars it's
only 5 dollars you could get a subway
footlong for C an hour of comedy
actually that is a bad choice to present
to you because if I were you I would
probably go anyway I've been you know
talking too much
in this so I'm gonna go get some stuff
done um so you know bye